uh scott is with us in atlanta georgia
hey scott what's up man
hello dave hey dr dalony first of all
dave congratulations
dr d is such a great addition to the
lineup well thank you
we agree you're welcome thanks brother
scott and your check is in the mail
brother
all right waiting for that um since i'm
on bs2 right now
so anyway uh to my question um
my wife and i like i said we're on baby
step too we've got a ways to go
uh we're currently cash flowing two kids
through college
my parents who are 80 years old never
saved for retirement
uh dave i called in last last year
you helped me guide me through bailing
my parents out of a financial crisis
and then you sent them through fpu and
set them up with a financial coach
they fully completed both and you also
sent me boundaries which i read
last month they called me to tell me not
ask me that they needed me to co-sign a
loan for them
because my mom wants cosmetic surgery
they can't afford
at 80. yeah
i don't even want to ask well
i could i could make it exciting but
it's uh it has to do with dental work
so i told them i was not going to
dismiss the principles i
live by to enable their behavior uh
especially after they ostensibly learned
the same thing i did
um anyway my birthday was august 30th
it came and went without a call or a
card
my father now spends time posting
passive aggressive stuff on facebook
about
how children are supposed to treat their
parents
now i know i'm right by not co-signing
and i'm not sure from a relationship
standpoint what i'm supposed to do here
i wouldn't let them starve or be thrown
out on the street but
this is a want not a need we're all
angry obviously
one of us is right uh but we're out of
style
hmm that hurts so bad i'm sorry
yeah scott i hate that for you brother
so here's the deal
uh when it comes to what's the right
thing to do financially of course you
know that you're right
and when it comes to the right thing to
do relationally
of course you know you don't need my
validation but you're right you drew a
boundary
that was best for you and for your
family and you held them to it and i'm
proud of you for that
and you're getting to see what the other
side of a boundary looks like when
someone pings
off your the walls or the fences or the
boundaries you drew
and they choose to react immaturely and
the hard part is
you love your parents you love your mom
you love your dad individually
and together and they're choosing to
make their own
path as adults are able to do and that
hurts and that stinks and you're going
to have to grieve that
but the reality is they're 80 they're
allowed to do whatever they want to do
and i would suggest you turn off
facebook and don't listen to the
nonsense
and you continue to be mature and you
continue to be adult
and yes you send them cards on their
birthday because
children honor their parents and you
make sure they're included when it's
appropriate but
you're gonna have to grieve this part of
it man because that just stinks
yeah i'm sorry i hate that for you the
only the only
recompense you've got is this there's
only one kind of a relationship
that requires money to be transferred
it's called prostitution
and so if your relationship is money
dependent
you're in that class you don't have a
relationship in other words
because that's not a relationship that's
a transaction agreed
uh i agree and so it's not to deal with
them
i'm just saying it's the only way you
have to get your brain around and
honestly it's chapter two i believe
maybe one even in boundaries
that says you're not crazy you remember
that chapter
you're not crazy because when you get
this ping off the boundary like john
described it
what you start to feel is is that you're
crazy like you did something wrong am i
a bad son am i being a legalist am i
being too hardcore
and so forth and it's like uh no
scott you were just asking how to deal
with this
well yeah i mean nobody wants to pick up
the phone at this point
and so here's the deal call them in and
check in how's everybody doing
you can be the mature grown up when
they're and if they choose to respond
in immature ways then then you can begin
to develop new boundaries against that
the challenge with boundaries is we feel
so good when we finally draw
and we forget that boundaries do have
consequences and
boundaries do have emotional and
feeling you know responses and sometimes
people don't respond well to our
boundaries and it hurts
a boundary is when someone feels like
their boundaries need when someone feels
like they're entitled to something of
yours that they're not entitled to
and you tell them that almost always
there's a response of anger
but i think we get so excited that we're
drawing a boundary that we feel good and
we do it and it's like ah
and we forget that then people come up
against it and say well then you're not
my son or i don't love you or
if my son really i can't do cocaine in
the living room dad then i just won't
let you be my dad if you're going to
throw me out for doing that well i'm
sorry we don't do cocaine in our living
room
or it's going to be your fault that my
kids are going to fill in the
right so people get to respond they're
going to respond your grandchildren are
going to be hungry because of
you because of you right now giving this
36 year old without
a job for two and a half years any money
you know this kind of thing and so it's
your fault somehow it's not your fault
man
i'm it does hurt it does it breaks your
heart
it's but i agree with john i mean just
call them and have a conversation but
here's the thing don't try to call them
and fix it
no there's nothing to fix they can't
they're not there's no
fixing this they're just going to get
over it or they're not
yeah and and i always want to encourage
people to be the mature party
be the respectful party the relational
party but also protect yourself and
don't keep putting yourself in harm's
way yeah
exactly i hate that for you scott it's
awful